l'école de la deuxième chance qui
possède trois antennes dans les ivelines
à ment au Mureau et à Saint-Quentin
Alassan est l'un des élèves inscrits à
Saint-Quentin en neline son témoignage
avec Valérie oribau et Patrick Jacques
de
dixmud histoire géographie sport et
cours sur l'actualité les matières
qu'alassan affectionnent le plus
pourtant autrefois il était peu assidu
aux activités scolaires et s'est
retrouvé en échec j'aimais pas trop
fermer dev voir et puis voilà quoi
c'était plus ça aussi je faisais j'ai
pas fait les efforts nécessaires avant
donc du coup j'étais largué l'exemple du
frère d'alassan passé par l'école de la
deuxème chance a convaincu sa maman
d'orienter son fils cadet vers cette
voie poussé un peu et puis aprèsah petit
à petit j'ai retrouvé la la volonté que
j'avais pas avant aujourd'hui Alassan
souhaite devenir animateur son parcours
un schéma classique pour ses élèves de
l'école de la deuxè chance de trpp
ouverte en 2007 une école qui s'adresse
aux jeunes entre 18 et 25 ans sortie du
système scolaire depuis plus d'un an et
sans diplôme ni qualification ici les
enseignements classiques sont dispensés
pour une remise à niveau en plus de la
découverte du monde de l'entreprise ils
s'adapte à nous en fait c'est un ils
sont avec nous ils nous suit chacun
c'est
individualisé pas de classe surchargée
les formateurs sont à l'écoute un
processus qui encourage les élèves
leur parcours ici ça n'est qu'une étape
et qu'il doivent se projeter loin très
loin voilà c'est ça qui est ça qu'on
apprend ici surtout l'idée est au bout
qu'au bout de 10 mois de formation ou
plutôt si c'est possible ils poursuivent
leur parcours soit en emploi directement
soit sur un établissement de formation
si le métier qu'il vise nécessite une
formation avec une première attestation
de compétences remise deux fois par an
70 % des élèves ici à traap obtiennent
un emploi ou s'orientent vers une
formation professionnelle plus
poussé ils sont nombreux comme Alassan
par exemple à venir dans vos
établissements combien de jeunes vous
accueillez actuellement B sur l'école de
50 en Eveline à trappe on accueille une
centaine de jeunes parents c'est c'est
l'objectif qu'on s'était fixé c'est un
peu ce qui nous réunit ce soir c'est que
le cè est arrivé al juste à la fin de
l'année on a on a bien travaillé on
arrive pile au bon moment cette année et
le but c'est pas d'en faire beaucoup
c'est c'est de le faire bien et puis
après ben de bien rentabiliser l'outil
donc de de les accueillir tous quoi là
vous accueillez le 100e élève cette
année sur cette formation sur l'année
2012 ils sont devenus quoi les 99 autres
alors il y en a encore plein qui sont
chez nous parce que le parcours du en
moyenne 10 mois donc on a une rentrée à
peu près tous les mois on accueille une
dizaine de groupes par an sur sur
chacune des écoles et en moyenne bah il
y en a une grosse quarantaine de pour
qui accède directement à l'emploi et
dans ces accès à l'emploi il y a aussi
les contrats d'apprentissage puisque un
contrat d'apprentissage bah c'est un
contrat de travail et puis après il y en
a 20 25 % qui qui accèdent à une
formation qualifiante alors qu' sont
souvent dispensé soit par l'AFPA soit
par le GRETA ou ou d'autres
qualifications professionnell mais la
majorité ce qu'ils veulent c'est l'accès
à l'emploi et parfois on entend que les
jeunes de maintenant ont plus envie de
travailler je pense que faut inviter ces
gensl chez nous vous verrez que les
jeunes de maintenant ils veulent
travailler c'est très important pour eux
ils veulent véritablement travailler
petit détail tout à l'heure dans le
reportage on entendait on parle de de
qualification que vous leur apportez ce
ce ne sont pas des diplômes non alors
nous on veut on veut pas être diplômant
parce que une partie de ce qui a pas
bien fonctionné et et et votre invité
précédent en parlait bien c'est c'est
cette histoire de programme on est
obligé un peu de de manger un menu qui
qui est parfois est trop conséquent
alors que là c'est plus à la carte c'est
totalement à la carte c'est ce que
disait Youssef il disait il s'adapte à
nous et et donc l'enseignement est
complètement individualisé vous avez vu
sur les images on a pas de salle de
classe on a' pas de tableau ni blanc ni
noir et cetera on est plutôt dans une
démarche de formation côte à côte on est
aussi dans une démarche de formation où
où les stagiaires eux-mêmes peuvent
céder entre eux parce que ils maîtrisent
pas tous les mêmes choses et et ça c'est
très bon pour la confiance et et et donc
on l'important c'est de progresser et
nous on accrédite des compétences
c'est-à-dire que l'addition et ben des
fois on arrive à l'école de la deuxième
chance on sait pas la faire alors
l'adition c'est rare il y en a beaucoup
beaucoup qui arrivent et qui savent la
faire et et puis à un moment et ben on
sait la faire et à ce moment-là et ben
on note nous en concertation avec le
stagiaère on a une évaluation et à
partir de là et ben cette addition on
sait la faire et à la fin de leur
parcours on leur remet un livret qui est
le livret des compétences acquises qui
fait une trentaine de pages pour chacun
et qui fait l'inventaire de tout ce
qu'ils savent faire et et ça c'est
extrêmement important et puis on résume
tout ça sur un beau diplôme
et arrive à ce diplôme c'est souvent le
premier qui arrive mais ça ce diplôme ça
s'appelle une attestation de compéten
acquises et il est différent pour chacun
et et au dos on reprend les les grandes
lignes de de ce qu'ils ont réussi à à
vérifier comme compét acquisees pour eux
parce que pour certains vous reprenez
tout à zéro ne serait-ce que le fait de
se lever le matin par exemple de venir
en cours d'être assidu on prend jamais
rien à zéro ils arrivent tous ils
arrivent tous avec une histoire ils
savent tous faire des choses et la
première chose qu'on reprend c'est cet
inventaire là et et et qui s'en rend
montrer qu'ils savent déjà des choses
voà qu'ils en prennent conscience et
puis après bah on n'est pas tous bons
sur les mêmes choses euh effectivement
il y a des jeunes qui qui ont adopté un
autre mode de vie qui qui sont restés
longtemps loin des obligations
professionnelles et scolaires et et qui
on basculer vers une vie un peu plus
noctambule mais ça c'est un problème
d'âge et effectivement bah nous ils sont
avec nous 35 he par semaine ce qui
nécessite qu'ils soit présent tous les
matins 8h30 et et et on en fait une
vérification pointilleuse et et 8h30
c'est pas 31 donc donc oui ça ça ça fait
partie des choses qui s'apprennent mais
à partir du moment où on veut travailler
c'est ce qu'on dont on parlait tout à
l'heure et ben on a l'énergie pour y
arriver le ner le nerf de la guerre
pardon c'est toujours l'argent les
finances il faut un peu d'argent pour
faire ça et en ce moment même si vous
préparez l'une des rentré qui se déroule
sur l'année la prochaine ce sera le 7
janvier d'ailleurs si des élèves des
jeunes sont intéressés peuvent toujours
se renseigner auprès de vos services he
pour pour être accueillis dans l'école
il
téléph c'est important le coup de fil
d'ailleurs c'est le premier contact et
je sais que vous y attachez beaucoup
d'importance donc vous parlez quand même
du ner de la guerre c'est ces finan
actuellement vous démarchez forcément
les entreprises et même en permanence
pour toucher cette taxe cette fameuse
taxe d'apprentissage alors 10 à 15 % de
notre budget effectivement dépend de la
taxe d'apprentissage alors on est
reconnu par l'État et on a le droit de
percevoir cette taxe d'apprentissage les
entreprise la paye quoi qu'il arrive
mais dans leur dans le paiement qu'elles
font elles peuvent soit laisser les
organismes collecteurs en faire une
répartition comme il le souhaite soit le
chef d'entreprise ou en concertation
avec ses salariés même s'il veut il
peuvent décider de l'attribuer à l'un ou
l'autre des organismes qui qui ont le
droit de de de percevoir cette taxe et
et l'école de la deuxième chance en fait
partie et et effectivement bah tous les
ans on remet en jeu les sommes mais Ben
10 à 15 % de notre budget en dépendent
donc
euh c'est ceement bah il y a toujours
une inquiétude parce que c'est quelque
chose don dont on n pas sûr il faut
convaincre c'est la taxe d'apprentissage
l'assiette c'est les salaires donc on
sait que la masse salariale elle est
plutôt dans un période de réduction donc
ben il y en a un petit peu moins à se
partager donc oui à chaque fois bah il y
a une inquiétude pour savoir si ce qu'on
projette de mettre dans notre budget ces
fameux 10 à 15 % bah on les aura bien et
et donc les entreprises doivent se
déterminer avant le mois de mars et et
puis nous c'est un argent qu'on reçoit
dans le courant de l'été mais il nous
servent à payer les salaires bah de du
dernier trimestre et et donc si on les a
pas on est très très embêté donc le
message à faire passer ce soir n'oubliez
pas garder dans un coin de votre tête
cette école de la 2ème chance pour
verser les taxes d'apprentissage merci
Hervé Demar d'être venu sur le plateau
l'école de la deuxième chance attrape et
qui vient de fêter son 100e jeune tout
simplement le 100e jeune dans l'année
seulement 2012 à être passé par chez
vous dans un instant on va parler de
l'environnement c'est la chronique de
l'environnement Valérie oribau va me
rejoindre